bonjour nous sommes jeudi 2 avril merci
de nous retrouver sur kiel échos votre
émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale
notre émission sera aujourd'hui consacré
à l'industrie à l'occasion de la 5e
édition de la semaine de l'industrie
je vous propose de découvrir le sommaire
de cette édition la 5e édition de la
semaine de l'industrie c'est en ce
moment à cette occasion vous feront
découvrir les différentes initiatives
mises en place dans les yvelines pour
pouvoir cette filière nous parlerons
également l'aéronautique avec
l'inauguration du nouveau pôle de
développement à toussus-le-noble un
projet d'envergure
enfin le contenu quelle fête son premier
anniversaire nous reviendrons sur ce
service financier alternatif proposé par
les buralistes et enfin dans notre
entretien cette semaine nous parlerons
également de la semaine de l'industrie
nous recevons virginie gagner et
dominique cousteix bonsoir à vous deux
vous avez tous les deux participé donc à
cette cinquième édition nous en
reparlerons tout à l'heure n'avance la
passe en revue l'actualité de la semaine
coup de projecteur sur l'aéronautique
aujourd'hui le nouveau pôle de
développement a été inauguré à toussus
le noble
cette inauguration s'est déroulée dans
le cadre de la semaine de l'industrie
plus de 400 jeunes étaient présents à
cette occasion mais aussi pour découvrir
les métiers de l'aéronautique
une façon de mettre également en lumière
le projet de développement d'un pôle
aéronautique autour de l'aéroport
écouter ces précisions recueillies au
micro de michael et demi d'euros écoutez
l'objectif c'est d'avoir rencontré des
collégiens et des lycéens de la
quatrième set pas jusqu'à la première s
est de leur montrer l'ensemble des
métiers l'ensemble des formations qui
permettent gérait bédarrides d'accéder
au domaine de l'aéronautique
toutes classes confondues ça va du bac
professionnel jusqu'au bac +8 donc tout
le monde a une place c'est pas parce
qu'on fait notre et aux technologies que
rooney réservé à des ingénieurs
c'est ce qu'ont laissé leur faire passer
comme message et la maison de
l'entreprise déménage c'est une
situation de transition en raison des
travaux de la médiathèque qui est
françois truffaut la maison de
l'entreprise avec les relocaliser dans
le bâtiment de promo paul à montigny le
bretonneux
rien ne change au niveau des horaires
tous les ateliers et réunions
d'information auront désormais lieu sur
le site de promo paul à montigny pendant
la durée des travaux
enfin vous l'avez certainement vu cette
semaine les buralistes sont au coeur de
l'actualité
mardi ils ont manifesté à paris pour
protester contre le paquet de cigarettes
neutre
ils ont également fêté récemment un
autre anniversaire mais celui ci a été
moins médiatisé les invendus compte
nickel ce service est proposé par les
buralistes
il permet d'ouvrir un compte en cinq
minutes accessible et peu coûteux il
séduit de plus en plus de français et
des viennois explications avec ma fille
qu'à berne et yolaine corrèze ouvrir un
compte en banque
c'est désormais possible et depuis plus
d'un an déjà le comte nickel c'est le
nom de ce service alternatif agrégés par
la banque de france dans les yvelines 5
buralistes ont décidé de tenter
l'expérience parmi eux
fabienne civelles à plaisir elle propose
le dispositif nickel depuis le mois de
février
49 comptes ont été ouverts chez elle le
but diversifier son commerce
vous savez très bien qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des problèmes dans le tabac et dans
la presse notamment
donc il faut trouver d'autres choses
pour faire rentrer des gens et pour
retravailler au départ je pense que
c'était plus sûr les gens qui avait pas
beaucoup d'argent qui arrivait pas avoir
de compte etc
maintenant tu étais tout et ce tous tout
le monde en fait
le système présente plusieurs avantages
notamment une plus grande amplitude
horaire que celle des banques à
l'étranger pas de frais supplémentaires
et la possibilité de déposer jusqu'à 750
euros par mois mais ce compte accessible
à tous a des limites
pas de chéquier ni de plan épargne est
impossible d'être à découvert au
distributeur un euro de frais pour les
retraits sur internet tous les virements
de compte à compte sont gratuits on y
voit au contraire 1 0 on a un appareil
pour scanner sa pièce d'identité
en cinq minutes près et après il peut
faire des dépôts qui lui coûte 2 % du
dépôt et il peut faire des retraits chez
nous c'est du coup de 50 centimes on le
distribue
et derrière c'est le conte nickel qui
gère comme comme un établissement
bancaire par notre intermédiaire pas
d'investissement pour les buralistes ils
perçoivent 2 euros par ouverture de
compte 23 centimes par retrait d'espèces
et touche une commission de 0,75 pour
cent sur chaque dépôt en france plus de
sept cents buralistes propos de comptes
nickel cela représente plus de cent
mille clients
la financière de paiement électronique
qui s'est associé à la confédération des
buralistes pour relancer le contenu
qu'elle espère attirer 150 me clients
supplémentaires d'ici la fin 2015 et
pour refermer cette page d'actualités
une information pour les jeunes à la
recherche d'un job d'été le département
recrute son cinquante étudiants dans le
cadre du dispositif
yes l'acronyme de yvelines étudiants
seniors après avoir reçu une formation
les jeunes rendent visite aux personnes
âgées à leur domicile
ce dispositif permet de favoriser les
échanges intergénérationnels et
l'enrichissement personnel
pour plus de renseignements rendez vous
sur le site du conseil général des
yvelines
je rappelle que ses services
proposée gracieusement ou personnes
âgées il est maintenant temps de
retrouver nos invités nous allons parler
industrie c'est l'entretien la semaine
et nous sommes en plateau avec virginie
galinier du club fasse je le rappelle le
club face et la fondation
c'est la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion et dominique cousteix est
directeur général de urban logistique à
elancourt vous connaissez bien la
semaine de l'industrie parce que vous y
avez participé tous les deux c'est la
cinquième édition donc cette année c'est
surtout destiné aux jeunes notamment
virginie vous avez organisé une visite
et participe à l'ambiance d'une visite
dans l'entreprise de monsieur cousteix
comment ça s'est passé on ne sait pas ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer alors en
fait j'ai prospecté plusieurs
entreprises et urban a répondu à cette
sollicitation ça s'est fait mardi
mardi dernier à 14 heures dont s'était
proposé pour des jeunes de l'action
allez les jeunes et pour un jeune aussi
de la mission locale de saint quentin en
yvelines qui souhaitent s'orienter vers
le secteur de la logistique
alors le bout de leur faire découvrir
des métiers ça alors c'était de leur
faire surtout découvrir le secteur de la
logistique parce que je peux enfin je
trouve qu'il est assez méconnue et je
pense que c'est à ses recruteurs
donc c'était découvrir les métiers et
principalement pour les jeunes pour
aussi de faire découvrir le monde de
l'entreprise tout simplement vous avez
accepté d'ouvrir vos portes à ces jeunes
tel est l'intérêt pour vous justement de
faire venir des jeunes et leur faire
découvrir votre entreprise l'intérêt il
est déjà pour les jeunes en tant que tel
comme a dit virginie c'est de leur faire
découvrir le monde de l'entreprise et en
l'occurrence pour nous le monde de la
logistique et c'est aussi les futurs
candidats pour les prochains posts qui
seront ouverts dans les prochaines
années
et pour ce faire aujourd'hui on a besoin
de gens qui soient formées
donc ça serait bien que certains de ces
jeunes s'orientent vers des formations
en l'occurrence en logistique
en ce qui nous concerne du mois et
pourquoi l'entreprise a enregistré le
monde au respect at il besoin de plaire
aux jeunes il m'a dit recul je pense
qu'il a une image qui est pas forcément
toujours très bonne au niveau du grand
public même si à priori j'ai lu dans la
presse récemment que cette image s'était
améliorée dans les trois dernières
années et pour moi il ya un fait
historique bon si on remonte une époque
plus ancienne voire zola industrie est
vu comme quelque chose de sale de
difficile
les postes sont réputés comme étant très
très dur c'est pas forcément très vieux
cette image là par contre ensuite il ya
les délocalisations ou du moins les
fermetures d'usinés récente qui donne
une très mauvaise image à l'industrie en
général
et puis ensuite les histoires qu'on peut
entendre au niveau des actionnaires qui
touche soi-disant plein d'argent donc
ces trois éléments entre autres je pense
que virginie sera d'accord là-dessus
font qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas toujours
très facile d'avoir une image qui me
disent les jeunes en général c'est
surtout qu'ils connaissent mal les
métiers donc c'est surtout valoriser ces
métiers là à les faire découvrir
après oui à la première chose c'est que
c'est salissant et mardi on a bien vu
que les salariés avaient des blouses des
chaussures de sécurité fin c'était pas
salissant du tout et même madame la ja
qui a organisé cette visite m'a fait
comprendre qu apparemment les vêtements
même des salariés étaient été lavé par
l'entreprise du coup tout de suite le
sar en face à en relève des freins que
peuvent se donner
est ce que dans les yvelines ce secteur
et il est toujours attractif je pense
notamment vous connaissez bien au niveau
de la logistique que vraiment il ya
quand même un regain dans l'industrie
aujourd'hui un regard vous savez comme
moi on a perdu des emplois en france
notamment je pense aussi dans les
yvelines
néanmoins il ya des postes à la fois en
logistique puisque partie moment on a
des flux de matériaux à transporter des
produits finis a transporté qu'il soit
fabriqué d'ailleurs dans la région ou
dans d'autres régions
on est obligé de faire appel à
logistique et aujourd'hui mes collègues
qui travaillent dans le monde réellement
industriels tels que l'aéronautique ou
l'automobile ont des besoins en
recrutement qu'il n'arrive pas à
pourvoir sur des postes peut-être un peu
technologique même pour n'importe quel
type de formation d'al à base de
l'opérateur d'opérateurs devient
technique il doit piloter des machines
complexes
donc il ya des besoins de formation real
et les jeunes doivent comprendre qu'il y
à ses besoins de formation et sur
justement ces formations vous dis c'est
à un peu sur toutes les fins le niveau
d'étude cd voilà il faut aussi un labeur
dubet du capc bac + 5 ils sont laissés
les profits qui sont les plus demandés
moi je pense qu'il ya à peu près tous
les tous les profils qui sont demandés à
ça va dépendre effectivement des
activités mais ça va pour moi du capjpo
voir bac pro en ce qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui on va recruter plutôt des
bac pro logistique pour des sociétés qui
font du montage bon j'ai des collègues
qui sont chez snecma et qui ont du mal à
recruter des menteurs ou des réparateurs
de moteurs d'avions ou virgin que vous
êtes beaucoup et en relation jetons avec
d'autres entreprises également qu'est ce
que vous entendez qu'est ce qu'on vous
dit à ce propos la va par exemple j'en
parlais monsieur coup sec tout à l'heure
thales par exemple ne cherche un ne
recrute plus actuellement d'ingénieurs
mais plutôt des ces apps et bac pro pour
des monteurs câbleur parce qu'ils ont un
manque beaucoup
donc l'idée même de thales et peut-être
de présenter leur métier à des filières
dans les lycées professionnels par
exemple pour promouvoir ces formations
là et les métiers bien sûr qu'ils sont
accessibles par ces formations et ce
sont encore des postes qui sont
intéressants pour les jeunes aujourd'hui
il ya des débouchés d'avenir vraiment il
ya des débouchés
il ya des débouchés d'avenir
effectivement avec l'évolution des
technologies
donc aujourd'hui on parle d'une
imprimante 3d qui m'ont ce pas
généraliser mais enfin qui vont se
développer au niveau des différentes
entreprises même nous dans notre métier
où on traite de la pièce de rechange on
peut se poser la question pour les
prochaines années si on n'aura pas des
imprimantes 3d pour réaliser quelques
pièces de rechange donc il ya une
évolution technologique on utilise des
outils informatiques
oui parce qu'en fait le souci c'est que
l'industrie pour les jeunes c'est ben
alors juridiquement l'automobile par
exemple parce qu'il y en a beaucoup les
soulever garçon qui fait mon mécanicien
aucun aussi mais il ya l'industrie
informatique l'industrie du numérique
il ya aussi l'industrie est
coresponsable avec toutes les normes
environnementales qui arrive enfin je
pense que quand même c'est des métiers
ou faut penser large et vert enfin si
orienté vraiment justement faut pas
entrer l'argent mais dans ce cas là
pourquoi les gens ne sont pas vraiment
intéressés à vous de parler
à l'heure du problème voilà un peu la
saleté qui pouvaient être un frein il ya
d'autres choses qui les freine un petit
peu à se diriger vers ce secteur là
alors moi je dirais par exemple par
rapport aux filles donc mardi on a eu la
chance il y avait deux filles
mais c'est vrai que c'est un métier où
il ya beaucoup d'hommes donc je sais que
madame la ja qui arrivait ya pas
longtemps à urbana valorisé un peu le
fait que les femmes soient intérêts dans
l'entreprise je trouve ça très bien donc
il ya peut-être aussi une action à faire
avec les filles pour valoriser ces
métiers là talès c'est pareil ils
aimeraient dans des lycées où il y est
pas mal de filles mais un en général les
classes et 80 % des garçons c'est une
réalité oui c'était une réalité
effectivement d'un jour du mâle noir
recruter gérer des femmes ou des jeunes
filles dans le monde industriel ou liés
à l'industrie j'ai des collègues
logisticiens qui travaille dans le
textile la celle inverse une majorité de
femmes
alors que chez nous c'est plutôt une
majorité d'hommes si ce n'est que
effectivement que m'a dit virginie
depuis quelques années anaya a réussi à
recruter un certain nombre de femmes et
qui font le même travail que les hommes
m'ont effectivement il peut y avoir
certaines charges un peu lourdes parfois
qu'ils ont du mal à déplacer mais elles
se font une idée est de toute façon on
aide par des moyens mécanisés le port de
charge un petit peu lourde je reviens ou
aux initiatives organisées dans le cadre
de la semaine ils ont juste pris
l'industrie par 10 la chambre de
commerce et nasri les yvelines organisé
un speed meeting auquel vous avez
participé
c'était important vraiment pour vous de
rencontrer les jeunes mais ce qu s'il
avait senti un intérêt les jeunes ont
rencontré des chefs d'entreprise doit
expliquer concrètement comment ça se
passait le monde des entreprises et de
l'industrie
oui je pense que les jeunes étaient très
intéressés pour le pour la majorité
d'entre eux quelques-uns étaient là
parce qu'on leur a demandé d'être là
mais la grande majorité était là par un
intérêt leurs intérêts étaient deux
ordres c'est connaître un peu le monde
de l'industrie et connaître des chefs
d'entreprise ou des responsables
d'entreprises qui étaient porteurs de
projets en fait là on touche du doigt
autre chose c'est l'entrepreneuriat et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est important
de se dire je peux être entrepreneur je
peux être entrepreneur simplement dans
une entreprise en tant que salarié donc
soit créé ma société soit est porteur
d'un projet au sein d'une entreprise et
c'est important d'avoir cette dynamique
également au niveau de nos jeunes quel
que soit leur niveau j'ai eu des classes
de stm g
j'ai eu des classes prépa en face de moi
il est de montrer une dynamique autour
de ça et d'un intérêt pour l'entreprise
vernis je vous vois réagir basse et ça
reflète enfin un peu une action qu'on a
parmi les missions
donc c'est l'action grain d'entreprise
donc en fait c'est aider des jeunes de
3e a créé leur mini entreprise en leur
faisant fabrique un produit de sa phase
de conception à sa phase de
commercialisation pour leur en montrer
un peu comment se crée une entreprise
surtout la dynamique de groupe
donc ça reflète un peu l'idée peut-être
de l'abandonner dsp sciences de base qui
sont dans le monde de rencontrer des
professionnels parce que c'est pas le
même contact qu'on a qui a été
professeur en fait oui alors en fait à
différentes phases du produit il ya des
professionnels qui viennent les aider
sur cette phase là et c'est concret
pense que cette approche grandes
entreprises est très importante on a
rencontré plusieurs fois nous des jeunes
qui étaient dans ce cursus je dirais en
classe de troisième où se joue une
orientation pour des formations qui vont
pour certains déterminer assez tôt leur
futur métier
donc c'est important que ces jeunes
touchent du doigt qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un métier qu'est ce que c'est que
l'entreprise
aujourd'hui le seul stage de cette
question je posais avant-hier à aux
jeunes les seuls stage qu'ils ont pu
faire dans le monde de l'entreprise
c'est le stage de 3e d'une semaine c'est
trop court une semaine ils ont rien ils
sont rendus compte d'un petit peu de
quelque chose mais ça suffit pas pour
moi il faudrait vraiment l'entreprise
soit beaucoup plus présente au niveau
des écoles routes les écoles soient plus
présentes dans le monde de l'industrie
services de stage peut-être ou organiser
je ne sais pas
les stages il faut le reconnaissez pas
toujours facile à organiser néanmoins
pour les entreprises c'est quand même
une seule charge donc des stages
peut-être ou des découvertes aussi
d'entreprises les entre des personnes
des entreprises des techniciens des
ingénieurs enfin tous les niveaux de
compos trouver dans les entreprises qui
interviennent comme s'est réalisée dans
le cadre de graines l'entreprise avec
face
actuellement qui interviennent pour
expliquer leur métier et l'intérêt
qu'ils aient trouve et vous avez rejoint
gagner selon vous quelles actions
doivent être menées va être amélioré
pour améliorer voilà le contact entre
les jeunes et l'industrie monde
professionnel belge tire et déjà des
actions qu'on met en place et qu'urban
participe donc c'est par exemple une
intervention en classe d'une salariée
qui présente ses métiers les visites
d'entreprises
ça peut aussi être des journées portes
ouvertes organisées par l'entreprise
elle-même par exemple iscar a fait ce
choix là pour ses métiers industriels
pour les valoriser en novembre et puis
ça peut être aussi je pense des journées
d'immersion dans l'entreprise pour voir
concrètement ce comment ça se passe avec
un salarié et on pourrait même faire un
on a eu une action qui s'appelle aller
les jeunes et qui est un dispositif
individualisé si une action prévention
contre le décrochage scolaire et
d'orientation choisi et donc ça pourrait
permettre à ces jeunes qui bénéficient
d'un tutorat sportif et professionnel à
pourquoi pas s'orienter vers ces métiers
là et d'ailleurs nous faisons l'objet
d'une participation aux trophées des
associations organisé par la fondation
edf
donc en fait de nombreuses associations
participent à ces trophées dans
différentes catégories et nous ont
quatre ans participe à la catégorie
lutte contre la précarité et le but
c'est de remporter le trophée du public
est une valeur de 10000 euros
donc plus vous serez nombreux à voter et
qu'on en a la chance d'emporter ses
perspectives face aide aussi les jeunes
à trouver dans ce jusqu'au lundi 4 mai
pour vous était bien le père le message
est passé voilà n'hésitez pas à regarder
donc soit site internet le banc doit
défiler et votez pour passes pour aider
cette initiative merci beaucoup virginie
galinier
et dominique ou steak d'être venu sur
notre plateau nous restons dans
l'industrie c'est l'heure du chiffre de
la semaine 40% c'est le pourcentage de
grands établissements du secteur
industriel franciliens installés dans
les yvelines
il faut comprendre par là des
établissements regroupant plus de mille
personnes le nombre élevé de grandes
exploitations est une des caresses
caractéristiques de l'industrie du
département ces vastes unités de
production canto également des
structures plus petites
huit établissements industriels sur dix
comptent moins de 20 salariés et nous
restons dans l'industrie illinoise avec
notre dossier de la semaine je vous le
disais en titre toute cette semaine et
jusqu'à dimanche de nombreuses
initiatives ont été organisées dans les
yvelines
le secteur de l'industrie tente de
dépoussiérer son image
les professionnels veulent montrer que
l'industrie technologique est un secteur
d'avenir avec des embauches à la clé du
collège à l'université tous les jeunes
évinois été visé cette semaine une
semaine pour rajeunir l'investissent et
un dossier réalisé avec william l
patrick jacques de dixmude williams roma
aurait traîné pardon pour le montage
donc là où vous voyez la ruche et 30
mètres de haut 2 150 mètres de long vous
apercevez des bâtiments complémentaires
un des connecteurs alex ans les sur
l'atrium l'avait nous méne street on est
dans la veine principale visite privée
du technocentre renault pas
d'ambassadeur ni de ministres parmi ces
jeunes pour la semaine de l'industrie
cette classe de lycéens et viennois se
voit exceptionnellement ouvrir les
portes du technocentre de guyancourt
n'est un moyen de découvrir cette
filière autrement mais en fait je suis
ingénieur en génie mécanique et j'ai
enseigné les sciences de l'ingénieur et
comme je suis dans un lycée où il n'y a
pas du tout de 2
l'industrie fin ils connaissent rien
j'ai voulu leur montrer ce que c'est aix
côté l'or parce que moi c'est mon métier
parce que je connais et je voulais
vraiment leur montrer qui a pas que la
svt la biologie qui a aussi les sciences
de l'ingénieur que c'est intéressant
qu'il ya plein d'autres métiers est
aussi ouvert aux filles graphisme
conception d'un prototype de voiture
les élèves découvrent les différentes
phases d'élaboration d'un véhicule une
image attractive de l'industrie est
différente de celle qu'ils s'imaginent
souvent j'ai trouvé ça exceptionnel ça
m'a fait très plaisir de découvrir et ça
m'a appris plein de choses sur la marque
renault et tous ses partenaires donc
voilà j'ai eu beaucoup apprécié on reste
quand même à l'école qu'on n'est pas
obligé de savoir ce qu'on veut faire
mais bon après c'est intéressant de
découvrir les métiers ce qui tout le
monde du travail
au lycée on n'a pas vraiment de
relations avec les entreprises sauf
peut-être les bacs professionnels
technologiques et c'est ce qu'ils font
ou le stage en filière générale
la joie on en fait pas du tout ni après
d'ailleurs je pense pas qu'on en fasse
donc voilà je souffrais que les vraiment
liens avec les entreprises des relations
que les industries s'efforce d'améliorer
l'enjeu pour elle est directement liée
au recrutement la gestion des emplois et
des compétences est primordial dans un
secteur où le vieillissement des
salariés et la montée en compétence de
certains métiers devient problématique
même pour de grandes entreprises
il ya beaucoup d'industries et dans les
yvelines ya de plus en plus
d'entreprises qui en tout cas sur le
territoire de 50 à vienne s'installer ça
veut dire que demain les meilleurs
jeunes pères au choix et donc nous avons
intérêt si nous voulons trouver demain
les meilleurs sur le marché nous aurons
intérêt d'ores et déjà à leur montrer ce
que nous sommes capables de faire dans
les yvelines l'industrie automobile
emploie près de 33 mille personnes soit
plus du tiers des emplois industriels du
département toutes filières confondues
le secteur industriel fait travailler
plus de 87 mille personnes dont plus de
4000 établissements
c'est près de 16 % des actifs viennois
des perspectives d'emploi méconnus des
jeunes pourtant directement concernés
pour eux l'industrie c'est l'automobile
automobile qui licencient mais
l'industrie c'est plein d'autres métiers
est et l'industrie du lait c'est
l'industrie du livre c'est l'industrie
de la cosmétique donc qui a vraiment sur
notre territoire une richesse
d'entreprises et de domaine
ce qu'il faut faire découvrir à nos
jeunes pour pallier ce manque
d'information sur l'industrie 20 chefs
d'entreprise du réseau coaction 78 ont
été invités à rencontrer une centaine de
jeunes du département lors d'un speed
meeting des rencontres et des
explications concrètes pour découvrir le
monde de l'industrie
le plus dur c'est d'ouvrir le plus
inquiétant
c'est très exigeant nous on est dans un
secteur un petit peu plus léger je crois
qu'on est à près de 5% de taux de
chômage ce qui est le plus bas de france
c'est des métiers où il n'y a pas de
chômage
un bac pro ou un bts avec une option
technique n'y a pas de chômage
le marché professionnel une réalité très
éloignées de celles des étudiants
on connaît pas grand chose sur
l'entreprise sur les industries donc ça
nous a permis de des food et tout ce
qu'on savait pas et c'était vraiment
très enrichissant
ça nous permet de nous ouvrir une
perspective pour l'avenir
c'est vrai que ça m'a quand même poussé
à me concentrer plus sur les gangs et
j'ai trouvé certains bakkour très
intéressant je pense que je vais faire
quelques recherches sur internet en
entrant parce que comment certaines
choses comme ça sans toi le secteur de
l'industrie souffre d'une image
vieillissante et ne séduit pas forcément
les jeunes un fait liée à la crise
économique
au cours de la dernière décennie
l'industrie française a perdu sept cent
quarante mille emplois et sa part dans
le pib a régressé de 21 à 13 %
mais d'après différents observatoires
cette tendance devrait bientôt
s'inverser
l'industrie représente une part
croissante des créations d'emplois
annoncées le nombre d'ouvertures du sinn
est lui en hausse il ya un vrai besoin
il ya vraiment des domaines qui manque
cruellement de jeunes de candidats que
ce soit par la formation en alternance
par la formation par apprentissage ou
par la formation
classique on va dire initial donc
effectivement c'est l'occasion de dire
aux jeunes venez on a besoin de vous on
a besoin de vos deux que vous suiviez
telle ou telle formation n'a besoin que
vous soyez là dans deux ans 5 ans 10 ans
l'alternance et l'apprentissage sont
aussi des axes mise en avant par la
semaine de l'industrie
mercredi un forum leur a été consacrée à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines
ici on encourage les étudiants à se
rapprocher des entreprises dans le cadre
de leurs études
ce projet s'inscrit dans un projet plus
global de la maison de l'emploi de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quai sur
sécuriser les parcours alternant à
l'issue de leur contrat en alternance
sachant que les grandes entreprises qui
sont présentes ici vous avez pu voir en
poche des alternants ils les gardent pas
à l'issue donc l'idée c'est de les
garder dans les pme du territoire dans
les yvelines le secteur a connu une
légère reprise entre 2010 et 2012
les exportations sont passées de 8,9 à
12 milliards d'euros d'ici 2020 cinq
cent mille postes seraient à pourvoir
dans le secteur de l'industrie sur toute
la france et passons maintenant à
l'agenda de la semaine
dans l'agenda de cette semaine de rendez
vous à ne pas manquer un des derniers
événements dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'industrie c'est la visite de trois
entreprises
la première kingsport une société leader
dans le secteur des abrasifs à 10h opéré
en yvelines et à rambouillet deux
visites ont lieu à 14h30 visite de
l'entreprise via pas qu'une société
d'assemblage et de services haute
technologie et à 16 heures découverte de
l'activité de police m un spécialiste
des équipements vétérinaire ces visites
sont organisées en partenariat avec la
maison de l'entreprise et de l'emploi
centre et sud yvelines
enfin si vous avez un projet de voyage
professionnel à l'étranger en europe et
à l'international
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines organise une réunion
d'information sur ce thème c'est le
jeudi 9 avril de 10 heures à 13 heures
un représentant divine information
jeunesse sera là pour vous conseiller et
répondre à toutes vos questions sur les
dispositifs les aides financières et les
modalités de voyage
c'est la fin de notre émission je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine à la même
heure pour un nouveau numéro de fil
échos